JUAN WILLIAMS, JESSE WATTERS
COMMAND BRIAN KILMEADE.
IT'S 5:00 IN NEW YORK CITY AND
THIS IS "THE FIVE" ."
WE'VE READ THE G.O.P. MEMO
ALLEGING SURVEILLANCE ABUSES BY
DOJ AND FBI INVESTIGATING THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
THE PRESIDENT ALSO DECLASSIFIED
THE DEMOCRATIC REBUTTAL.
WE ARE AWAITING A DECISION FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> THE PRESIDENT HAS SEEN THE
MEMO.
HE MET WITH DEPUTY
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROD ROSENSTEIN
WITHIN THE LAST HOUR TO DISCUSS
SOME OF THE DIFFERENCES BETWEEN
THE TWO MEMOS.
AND WE ARE UNDERGOING THE EXACT
SAME PROCESS THAT WE DID WITH
THE PREVIOUS MEMO IN WHICH IT
WILL GO THROUGH A FULL AND
THOROUGH LEGAL AND NATIONAL
SECURITY REVIEW.
FINDINGS OF THE DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS AND STAKEHOLDERS
INVOLVED AND WILL MAKE A
DETERMINATION AT THAT TIME.
>> Dana: DEMOCRATS SAY THEY
WANT THEY WANT TO RELEASE AS
QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE BUT THEY ARE
ALSO VOICING SOME CONCERN.
>> WHAT I AM MORE CONCERNED
UNFAVORABLE TO THE PRESIDENT.
THAT COULD BE A REAL PROBLEM AND
THAT'S OUR MAIN CONCERN AT THIS
POINT.
IT WILL CERTAINLY APPEAR THAT
THE WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO
STONEWALL AGAIN IF, IN FACT,
THEY MAKE THESE POLITICAL
REDACTION'S THAT WE FEAR.
>> Dana: THERE IS A THEORY
COULD BEAT A TRAP FOR THE
PRESIDENT.
SOURCE TELLS FOX NEWS THEY WERE
I GUESS THAT'S A PLOY SOMEONE
COULD USE IF THEY WANTED TO MAKE
IT'S A MADE-FOR-TV MOMENT.
ADAM SCHIFF WILL RUN TO THE
PODIUM, PROBABLY POLO LEG MUSCLE
TRYING TO GET THERE.
LOOK AT THIS, IT'S ALL REDACTED.
IT IS A MADE-FOR-TV MOMENT AND
THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE HOPING FOR.
SO BAD AND DAMAGING FOR THE
PRESIDENT, WANTS TO KEEP IT OUT,
WANTS TO KEEP FROM THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE, ONLY WANTS TO RELEASE
WAS FAVORABLE TO HIM.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO DISTRACT,
THAT'S THE ARGUMENT OF WHAT THEY
WILL SAY.
THERE'S A LITTLE BIT OF A RISK,
YOU CAN'T RELEASE ONE AND NOT
RELEASE THE OTHER.
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRATS REALLY
>> Juan: THEY ARE UNABLE TO
KIMBERLY SAID IT, SHOULD BE
RELEASED IN THE NAME OF
TRANSPARENCY WHICH WAS THE
THE ONLY PROBLEM THERE WAS THAT
THERE WAS SOME WHICH CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION NOT ATTACHED.
IT'S HARD TO FULLY GAUGE WHETHER
OR NOT THEY ARE MAKING A SERIOUS
CASE OR IT'S JUST ABOUT
DISCREDITING THE FBI, DEPARTMENT
QUESTIONS ABOUT CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ATTACHED.
THE ISSUE FOR ME IS ONCE YOU
AGREE TO LET OUT THE REPUBLICAN
MEMO, HOW CAN YOU NOT LEFT OUT
THE DEMOCRATS RESPONSE?
THE ONLY ISSUE HERE IS WHETHER
OR NOT PRESIDENT TRUMP, FEELING
HE'S BEING INTENTIONALLY LURED
INTO A TRAP, DECIDES NO, I'M NOT
GOING TO DO IT AND DOESN'T GIVE
A HOOT WHAT ANYBODY HAS TO SAY
EVEN THOUGH HE IS THE ONE WHO
PUT ON THE DOG AND PONY SHOW
THAT STARTED IT.
>> Dana: MY SENSE, JESSE, IS
THAT THE WHITE HOUSE WILL
RELEASE IT AS LONG AS IT DOESN'T
COMPROMISE SOURCES AND METHODS
MAY BE IF THERE IS SOME SORT OF
TRAP AND THERE THEY MIGHT TRY TO
GO BACK TO THE DEMOCRATS AND SAY
YOU NEED TO FIX IT.
MY SENSES THEY WERE GOING TO
RELEASE IT.
>> Jesse: THEY WILL.
THE DEMOCRATS ARE RUNNING
SCARED.
MEMO.
THEY ARE SAYING IT'S NOT A BIG
DEAL BECAUSE THEY KNOW IT'S A
BIG DEAL BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
ADDRESS THE FACTS IN THE
MARRIAGE.
I DON'T TRUST SCHIFF.
HE HAS A PROVEN LIAR AND A
TESTIMONY.
AND THEN HE SAID THIS MEMO WAS
GOING TO JEOPARDIZE NATIONAL
TRYING TO TRAP THE PRESIDENT
INTO REJECTING SOMETHING.
WHO KNOWS WHAT THE PRESIDENT IS
SECURITY.
THEY KNOW THEY HAVE TO PLAY
GAMES BECAUSE THEY CAN'T ADDRESS
THE ABUSE THEY UNDERTOOK AT
THEIR OWN JUSTICE DEPARTMENT AND
FBI.
THE REAL COLLUSION IS WITH
HISTORY AND THE RUSSIANS.
SHE WAS THE ONE THAT PAID FOR
WIRETAP ON THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
COMEY BETTER LAWYER UP BECAUSE
HE KNEW IT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
THAT IT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
YET HE WAS THE ONE THAT BROUGHT
THAT'S AGAINST THE LAW.
YOU CANNOT PRESENT UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION TO A FISA JUDGE.
HE IS IN BIG TROUBLE.
ALSO, WHY DID HE DELIVER THIS
UNVERIFIED DOCUMENT
PRESIDENT-ELECT TRUMP WHEN HE
KNEW HILLARY PAID FOR IT BUT
DIDN'T TELL THE PRESIDENT-ELECT
THAT HILLARY PAID FOR IT.
THE DAY AFTER HE BRIEFED THE
PRESIDENT ON THE DOSSIER, IT
LEAKS.
VERY SUSPICIOUS.
>> Juan: IF I WAS A JUDGE I
WOULD SAY LAWYER, COUNSELOR,
ONE THING.
>> Juan: BECAUSE THE STEELE
DOSSIER MAY HAVE BEEN PAID FOR
BY THE CLINTON CAMPAIGN, SHOULD
>> Jesse: IT WAS UNVERIFIED.
YOU DON'T TAKE UNVERIFIED
INFORMATION TO A FISA JUDGE.
>> Juan: YOU DON'T KNOW WAS
UNVERIFIED.
WE DON'T KNOW IT WAS UNVERIFIED.
>> Jesse: CALL ME SAID IT WAS
UNVERIFIED.
>> Juan: NO HE DIDN'T.
>> Jesse: YES, HE DID.
HE SAID IT WAS UNVERIFIED AND
SALACIOUS.
AND WHAT'S ON THE DOSSIER THAT'S
BEEN VERIFIED?
OUR OWN BRAIN ROOM SAYS --
ARE YOU GOING TO GO AGAINST YOUR
OWN COMPANY ON THIS AND COMEY?
YOU JUST HAD COMEY AND FOX NEWS.
>> Dana: WOW.
>> Juan: YOU ARE OUT THERE,
BUDDY.
>> Jesse: THIS WHOLE HOAX IS
IMPLODING AND YOU'RE TRYING TO
COVER IT UP.
>> Dana: NOT SURE IT IS
HELPING.
>> Brian: THERE IS A GIANT
DONALD TRUMP LOOMING OVER YOUR
SHOULDER.
[LAUGHTER]
I WOULD LIKE TO BACK -- THIS IS
WHO IS GOING TO HELP HEAL THE
SHOW.
I LIKED IT BACK
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" EFFORT TO
FISA COURT AND WE WILL KNOW ONCE
1978 WHAT REALLY WENT ON IN
ORDER TO WIN OVER THAT JUDGE.
UNTIL PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
ELECTED.
THE JUDGE SITS THERE BY HIMSELF.
FBI SAYS CAN YOU TAKE A LOOK AT
>> Dana: IT'S A LITTLE MORE
DIFFICULT THAN THAT.
>> Brian: I WOULD LIKE A
WARRANT.
WE WILL TAKE A LOOK.
JUDGING BY EVERYTHING I SEE, I'M
ONLY GOING TO REJECT 12.
IT'S RUBBER-STAMPED STAMP AND
PUT FORWARD.
THERE'S TWO THINGS THAT ARE
GOING TO BE INTERESTING TO FIND
OUT IN THIS MEMO.
WITHOUT THE DOSSIER.
THEY SAY IT'S TAKEN OUT OF
CONTEXT BUT THE QUOTE IS
ACCURATE.
THROUGH LAUGHTER OR SOMETHING.
THE SECOND THING, THE FOOTNOTE
THAT PAID FOR THE DOSSIER.
DIDN'T SAY HILLARY FOR AMERICA
OR DEMOCRATIC NATIONAL COMMITTEE
BLATANT WAY TO SAY WHO PAID FOR
THE DOSSIER THAT MIGHT'VE
HAVE THE TRANSCRIPT.
THAT'S WHAT WE NEED TO SEE.
IF I AM A JUDGE, THE FOLLOW-UP
QUESTION WOULD BE WHAT'S THE
NAME OF THE ORGANIZATION THEY
GAVE YOU THIS DOSSIER.
>> Juan: WHAT DOES IT MATTER?
THINGS ABOUT ME BEFORE I GET
THERE, YOU ARE DISPOSSESSED TO
HATE ME.
THE PEOPLE AT A POLITICAL
LET'S SEE THE ARGUMENT, THE
TRANSCRIPTS.
REQUESTS ON CARTER PAGE WAY
THEY HAD TO BE APPROVED,
ESPECIALLY THE LAST CASE BY ROAD
ROSENSTEIN -- ROD ROSENSTEIN.
>> Brian: WHY DO YOU NEED THE
DOSSIER?
FIVE TIMES YOU NEEDED THE
DOSSIER.
>> Juan: THE DOSSIER DOESN'T
EXIST UNTIL LATE 2016.
TO PROVE THERE IS STILL A NEED
TO BE FOLLOWING SOMEBODY.
I'M NOT NECESSARILY THINKING WE
NEED TO OPEN UP -- IT'S A
CROWDSOURCING BY PEOPLE LIKE US.
I AM NOT QUALIFIED.
>> Kimberly: UNDERMINES THEIR
ABILITY.
>> Brian: IT DOESN'T INVOLVE
US.
IF I AM CARTER, I WOULD LIKE
THE WORLD.
IF SOMEONE IS SURVEILLING ME
>> Dana: CARTER PAGE FROM THIS
>> THESE ARE YOUR WORDS.
I SERVED AS AN INFORMAL ADVISOR
TO THE STAFF TO COME HERE,
ADVISING THE KREMLIN.
>> WE WERE PART OF AN INFORMAL
GROUP, MEETING IN GENEVA, PARIS.
>> NEW YORK STOCK EXCHANGE.
WHAT I HAVE SEEN THUS FAR IS
RIDICULOUSNESS.
>> YOU'VE BEEN UNDER
SURVEILLANCE SINCE OCTOBER 2016.
SINCE THAT TIME, HAVE YOU EVER
SPOKEN TO DONALD TRUMP?
>> I'VE NEVER SPOKEN WITH HIM
SINCE.
I'VE NEVER SPOKEN WITH HIM ANY
TIME IN MY LIFE.
>> NO EMAIL, NO TEXTS COME UP.
>> NEVER.
ELECTION FOR TRUMP.
>> Jesse: NOT THE SHARPEST
KNIFE IN THE DRAWER.
THEY JUST RELEASED DOCUMENTS
FROM 2015 FROM THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT THAT SAID CARTER PAGE
ACTUALLY HELPED THE FBI PUT AWAY
RUSSIAN SPIES AND EXPOSED THEM,
THAT WERE INFILTRATING OUR
SYSTEMS.
EITHER HE IS A DOUBLE AGENT,
WHICH HE IS NOT CLEARLY.
I DON'T THINK HE IS NOT SMART.
OR WHY WOULD THE RUSSIANS
RECRUIT HIM AGAIN AFTER HE
HELPED PUT RUSSIAN SPIES AWAY A
FEW YEARS AGO?
IT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE.
AND HE'S AN INFORMAL, UNPAID
ADVISOR TO THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
IT DOESN'T ADD UP WHY YOU WOULD
OPEN UP AN INVESTIGATION.
>> Brian: IT IS SO CLEAR THAT
PAPADOPOULOS AND HE THREW THE
ELECTION FOR TRUMP.
IT IS SO OBVIOUS.
A GUY HE NEVER TALKED TO OR